Here's a prayer for our children, from every parent's heart.
She was taught to trust your name, believe the same recited scripture saying the songs.
She learned the verses, read the stories, prayed the prayer, oh, what went wrong?
Was it me?
Did I not believe?
Was my faith at you too shaky?
Were my actions inconsistent with your truth?
Was I rebellious and it shows now in her life?
Was it lack of understanding, lack of teaching, lack of faith, lack of fruit?
Did we do our best but our best was done in flesh that never pleases?
Did we rely on works that could never win a sitter's soul?
When we raised a child in Christ, I thought the guarantee was that they'd love you, as
long as we did our parental role.
Should I wish to change an instant in the past or to question fleshly acts that could never
last?
Should I remember that it's you who saves?
It's me who just receives.
Should I pray for gifts of grace for her and hope for us who grieve?
Should I trust the plan you have contains the pain of unbelief to draw us near your heart
to see the lost?
Is it part of the inclusion in the kingdom for my soul to cry for those who will not cannot
count the cost or let the cry of the aching heart be heard up in the heavens like an incense
so thick it burns the eyes?
Or if the prayers of a faithful soul, are glory in the sky, let this request be always
on my mind, my heart, it burns for our children who turn their backs untruth.
They run away from reason to follow golden dreams, the world may probe us riches, happiness
and temporary pride.
But hear my prayer and gather them a good close to your side.
Lord, take the hearted heart and bake it soft again.
Take the unbelief and let it bird with fire.
You give faith and love and gifts just like their gift out.
Uncrismacy, Lord, give my daughter the ability to believe.
Remember me, I'm the lost whose eyes you opened, the lame you did set free.
Remember me, I'm the leopard now forgiven, the doubter who believes it wasn't I.
I read from truth so often when you had me on your leash, pull back the reins on the
lost, do for her just as you did for me, break the chains that bind them, drop the scales
that blind their eyes, turn back that hidden switch so they may see.
Lord give our sons and daughters the power to repent, the desire to seek, the hunger to
know you and the faith to believe.